question from nyada thomas were marquis
and mike pouncey the best twins in nfl
history shireen your thoughts
well i went back and looked mike and
they rank right up there and i think
they they're all modern that that i
think rank right up there in nfl history
marquis and mike uh combined for 13 pro
bowls and two all pros i would rank the
barbers ahead of them rondae and tiki
ronde was a finalist for the pro
football hall of fame
they combined for eight pro bowls and
four all pros and and i'd put devin and
jason mccourty right up there with them
too
yeah you know marquis has a chance to
get in the hall of fame nine pro bowls
three first team all pros which are
significant was i don't know if he was
on the team of the decade you you know
that was he was he on the the i believe
he was yep the old decade team i think
that's going to help him get in uh no
super bowl wins but a super bowl
appearance in his rookie year so i think
he's got a chance to get in just like
rondae does and tiki would have a better
chance long term than mike i don't think
mike's ever getting in he's got three
pro bowls to his name but it's a pretty
good set of twins the exact same
position the exact same number two
different teams though obviously
throughout the course of their careers
one more quick question gone show west
and this is an important question as
relates to nfl ownership as the captain
of the sinking ship known as the houston
texans is cal mcnair a cautionary tale
to the nfl on what the approval criteria
should be for a team owner this is a
great question shireen because
once your dad gets in
and the team goes to you
there's no approval process that i know
of i'm gonna look into this but i don't
think that anytime there's an
inheritance of a team once a family owns
it you don't have to go through any
scrutiny you don't have to go through
any minimal qualifications you just take
over and that's the thing that i love
about the nfl and i don't love it
because i think it's great i love it
because i think it's fascinating all the
money that's put into football
operations and the teams are ultimately
run by a series of monarchies where it
goes to this child it goes to that child
it goes to that sibling and they may not
know a damn thing about running a
football team
yeah exactly right mike and i assume
right now that janice would probably be
listed as the owner bob mcnair's wife
and cal is running the team because i
don't think he actually has the owner
title but he certainly is running the
team and representing the mcnair family
and it is funny how these things work
you know here in dallas when when
jerry's gone and let's hope it's a long
time before he's gone because he's great
for the nfl but once jerry's gone you
know i imagine that the kids will run
the show with steven uh being the voice
of the team but charlotte will have us
say and jerry jr will have a say and
it's just kind of passed down uh for
most teams you see the broncos and what
they're going through but normally these
things just go down the line and the
next generation takes over mike
important point to keep in mind and i'm
not going to go too deep into the rabbit
hole but the estate tax issue becomes
critical and the smart teams will will
finagle the ownership percentages to try
to minimize the amount that the
patriarch or matriarch hold at the time
of the passing because there have been
teams that have been sold in the past i
think of washington when jack kent cook
passed the dolphins when joe robbie died
you don't have the revenue you don't
have the money you don't have the cash
to pay the estate taxes and also
run and hold the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports